it'd be great if you could tell us a
little bit about what it's like on site
because are all the observations
firsthand are there are there cameras
around what's what's what's the nature
what's the size what's the nature of
this condition so when you are this is
how it works at Gombe it's a little bit
different at Kara Sookie and Rwanda
because they're they have more limited
time with the gorillas but what I do
when I'm I call me is that I wake up
very early in the morning we know where
the chimps have slept the night before
because they actually build a night nest
in the trees and if you follow them
until late in the day when they build
that nest you're like great that's where
he'll be at 6:00 a.m. tomorrow so you
wake up so that you're with them at 6
a.m. and what our on-site researchers do
is they follow a single kind of focal
individual all day from the time they
get up till the time they go to bed and
they're taking a series of consistent
data every 15 minutes but then taking
longhand data throughout the day about
interesting things like mating and
grooming and fighting and all that kind
of stuff so you're on foot in the
morning a chimp comes down from the tree
wake up time is a really good time to
collect fecal samples by the way just
makes sense if you think about it right
so you get there in the morning collect
all your samples then you're with the
chimps all day and you're following them
at a distance of about 7 meters that's
what we consider kind of a safe distance
for them and for us they break it often
because you're either in their way or
they're curious so like me to the the
fourth row and you're just you're with
them and recording everything they do
all day now we have several teams out we
have a team that's that's focused on the
adults and we also have a specific team
focused on mothers and kids as part of
this grant so there's gonna be multiple
teams out in the day following
individual chimpanzees around
documenting their behavior where they go
what they eat collecting samples all day
and that has been going on essentially
unchanged since 1966 and you and you're
based in Pennsylvania but you're out
there how many I'm out there once a year
uh-huh
when I was a student I could go more but
then I invest
to my own offspring it all went downhill
from there these expensive children I
was we've got another question in the
back there I'm interested in childbirth
no could you talk a little bit about it
sociology where the mother goes anything
about me
so just make sure you're holding it
closer we can hear you childbirth
anything about how many individuals are
around when the child is when the infant
is born first treatments yeah so the
question for if you guys couldn't hear
it was about childbirth and the act of
childbirth and and how that happens in
Apes and in chimpanzees interestingly
enough a colleague of mine is finalizing
a paper and analysis of that right now
but it's highly variable so that's the
important thing to point out about
chimpanzees is that they are extremely
aggressive within their own community
and infanticide is a real risk from from
strangers chimpanzees but also from
chimpanzees in your community both males
and females so a newborn baby is
incredibly vulnerable its mother is
subject to infanticidal attacks and so
because of that what often happens is
that mom goes on a bit of a maternity
leave and wants to be by herself when
she gives birth to that baby now we of
course have outliers we have a very had
she's passed away now a very dominant
female named Fifi who had more babies
than anybody else she's the one in that
picture
touching Jane I mean she's kind of the
best documented animal I think on the
planet very comfortable in her community
and also with humans and she would give
birth like right in front of tourists
like just like you know her her sons
were always alpha male like she wasn't
worried about this infanticidal thing
rock star behavior yeah but typically
there is a real maternity leave and we
don't know much about it because if they
decide to be where we can't find them we
can't find them so I can't answer
your question really well because we
don't get to see it very much
[Music]